in the previous example we had a model
where the result of the first coin toss
did not affect the probabilities of what
might happen in the second toss this is
a phenomenon that we call independence
and which we now proceed to define let
us start with the first attempt at the
definition we have an event B that has a
certain probability of occurring we are
then told that event a occurred but
suppose that this knowledge does not
affect our beliefs about B in the sense
that the conditional probability remains
the same as the original unconditional
probability thus the occurrence of a
provides no new information about B in
such a case we may say that event B is
independent from event a if this is
indeed the case notice that the
probability that both a and B occur
which is always equal by the
multiplication rule to the probability
of a time's the conditional probability
of B given a so this is a relation
that's always true but what if we also
have this additional condition then this
simplifies to the probability of a
time's the probability of B so we can
find the probability of both events
happening by just multiplying their
individual probabilities it turns out
that this relation is a cleaner way of
defining formally the notion of
independence so we will say that two
events a and B are independent if this
relation holds why do we use this
definition rather than the original one
this formal definition has several
advantages first it is consistent with
the earlier definition if this equality
is true then the conditional probability
of event B given a
which is the ratio of this / that will
be equal to the probability of B so if
this relation holds then this relation
will also hold and so this more formal
definition is consistent with our
earlier intuitive definition a more
important reason is that this formal
definition is symmetric with respect to
the roles of a and B so instead of
saying that B is independent from a
based on this definition we can now say
that events a and B are independent of
each other and in addition since this
definition is symmetric and since it
implies this condition it must also
imply the symmetrical relation namely
that the conditional probability of a
given B is the same as the unconditional
probability of a finally on the
technical side conditional probabilities
are only defined when the conditioning
event has nonzero probability so this
original definition would only make
sense in those cases where the
probability of the event a would be
nonzero in contrast this new definition
makes sense even when we are dealing
with zero probability events so this
definition is indeed more general and
this also makes it more elegant
let us now build some understanding of
what independence really is suppose that
we have two events a and B both of which
have positive probability and
furthermore these two events are
disjoint they do not have any common
elements are these two events
independent let us check the definition
the probability that both a and B occur
is zero because the two events are
disjoint they cannot happen together on
the other hand the probability of a
time's the probability of B is positive
since each one of the two terms is
positive
and therefore these two expressions are
different from each other and therefore
this equality that's required by the
definition of Independence does not hold
the conclusion is that these two events
are not independent in fact intuitively
these two events are as dependent as
Siamese twins if you know that a
occurred then you are sure that B did
not occur so the occurrence of a tells
you a lot about the occurrence or
non-occurrence of B so we see that being
independent is something completely
different from being disjoint
independence is a relation about
information it is important to always
keep in mind the intuitive meaning of
independence two events are independent
if the occurrence of one event does not
change our beliefs about the other it
does not affect the probability that the
other event also occurs when we have
independence in the real world the
typical case is when the occurrence or
non-occurrence of each of the two events
a and B is determined by two physically
distinct and non interacting processes
for example whether my coin results in
heads and whether it will be snowing on
New Year's Day are two events that
should be modelled as independent but I
should also say that there are some
cases where independence is less obvious
and where it happens through a numerical
accident you can now move on to answer
some simple questions where you will
have to check for independence using
either the mathematical or the intuitive
definition